hi
where are we gonna put all the stuff
we're off on a car adventure
[Music]
we've made it to the grove we're
checking in i don't think i told you
guys what we're doing today
the f1 race is happening and we are
borrowing a mclaren
to go watch the race at the grove in the
parking garage
with other people with cool cars a lot
of these people their cool cars are
actually their cars
um this is not my car
today this is my car tomorrow i gave it
back mind it
mask on ready to roll
[Music]
this is incredible come on we are not
cut out for mclaren
[Music]
so the race is about to start we all
have to get into cars because they're
going to take some aerial photos
you know i did bring my drone but i feel
like probably shouldn't fly it because
in case
it drops on one of these you know
million dollar vehicles there's this
really cool ferrari up here
that is not even street legal in the us
how did it get here
did they do car crime they didn't that's
[Music]
cool
do
[Music]
so jordan's here and i completely forgot
that we were there the day you got this
i was like you've seen this before right
i swear
and then yeah you brought up oh yeah you
were at the the delivery day on it
did i was three years ago i know i
wonder if i made a vlog i'm sure there's
a vlog somewhere of us all in i made a
vlog
you made a vlog i don't know if you did
i think you probably took some photos or
something what do you think
what do you think i love it crazy it's
been that long my warranty's expired
so now i'm i did my last service with
the warranty
i'm sure it's gonna be really fun
whenever anything else comes up
yeah i feel like it's probably you know
kind of expensive to uh
do some maintenance it's not cheap so
the mclaren that we're borrowing the
first question that jenna asked was
are we able to drink or eat in it
because our friend jordan we weren't
allowed to eat or drink and
so i was pushing it a little bit they
said everybody sit in your cars for the
start of the race and there's
this coffee that was delivered there i
was like oh god
can i so i pour it outside i'm like
leaning over the sill and then i
i took sims that's the first non-water
beverage i've ever
had to drink in that car so it's a real
accomplishment no i mean i'm impressed i
know that probably honestly like you
were dying inside
it was kind of terrifying yeah everyone
watching this is like
bro you need to loosen up but also wow
those wheels are nice still like a
carbon fiber
like oh wow yeah there aren't too many
manufacturers that offer that
it's pretty cool it's unique i don't
even have a car right now you just keep
getting press cars so you don't really
need one clarin to
mustang maki chevy what have you well
it's like my car stopped working
and now it's fixed but like i don't have
room because i've got all these borrowed
cars
so because i went from like no cars to
now i have too many cars it's a really
it's a youtuber problem right now
how much space is in your driveway
without making your neighbors really
angry
it's not a lot we were in trouble
oh my god is that ijustine from the
mclaren gt yes
it is i whoa
[Music]
sir lewis hamilton has crossed the line
he took it
he is unbeatable he really is i mean
that's who i was cheering for
sir he was really is that tommy
who were you cheering for i mean i lando
did well in fourth place
yeah i was playing in twitch rivals with
him so i feel like i have to give him a
cheer yeah
it was a really solid lineup this year
and i just think
everyone did great and on that note heck
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
we got up so early today and now we're
doing this drive
and it's it's so amazing i do see why
people do this driving because there's
like a lot of cars
so you need to you know get up here real
early
next time we've learned there's a lot
have never been more terrifying than
they are right now
[Music]
oh man we did it we did it we did it we
did it but this is not the end of the
adventure you need to go take a nap
reassess and then jen and i are going to
go out for sunset
i'm so glad we have this this roll out
safety mat
i hit my head so hard getting out of the
car
you hit your head so hard i hit my head
three times getting it out of the car
i'm just not used to it
so that's round two of the adventure i'm
picking jenna up and we're gonna go to
dinner and then we're gonna catch the
sunset
because we're going to manhattan beach
which makes me a little nervous parking
is gonna be a struggle oh there she is
there's jenna i gotta go get her
ah oh we we need to unlock
hey where's the fridge uh it's in the
front
oh it's actually in the front how's it
fit
is i put the mini xbox fridge
in the front jen welcome to the vehicle
back again who are you talking oh i was
like who are you talking to
our friends
we're going to dinner we're going to
love and salt it's going to be so
freaking good
i just want to say like i've driven a
lot of cool cars before
but never i've never driven a mclaren
i've never driven like super super
super super cool cars i mean and i just
want to say
i get it now yeah i never freaking get
it i didn't get it
that's why they're super cars i get it
super cool i
am so sad that i've made it this long
without it it's probably a good thing it
is probably a good thing because i would
probably
um i'd probably i'd probably have
several mclarens at this point and i
would whoa
flex netflix well i might be living in
them because i probably would have a
house
[Music]
the thing about manhattan beach is
there's a lot of like roads
yeah with different angles and hills and
that kind of scares me
we're new to this low car life we're new
to the life that is low to the ground
it's terrifying down here
i'm so low i like it's crazy how low
like i could slide under this minivan
this is sorrento
please don't i'm gonna go under please
don't i would that's how you die
no we would go right underneath no
we are inside of a restaurant right now
it feels like we're committing some sort
of a crime
but we're so far away from everybody
it's crazy
it's so funny it's just weird
you think that i coordinated today when
you're inside a restaurant i don't know
how to feel
i feel hungry we're very far away like
there's no there's no one by the way
there's nobody
there's like more than six feet
hey can you i wanna i wanna i want them
to hear the sound of this starting up
okay carson
yeah you know what else we pop this in a
sport
there's a car coming you hear that
i'm honestly gonna just listen to loose
of mclaren
car revving engine that's nice
so the beach the beach did not work out
because the parking lots were so crowded
because it was finally a nice day in l.a
so we settled for uh
well i was gonna say a very abandoned uh
alleyway just there's a car coming
there's a car coming oh okay they can go
around
you know it's a sunday
[Music]
i need to show you guys what's in the
trunk oh xbox fridge
are you gonna get the tick-tock shot so
you guys have seen the dude on tick tock
where he asks
people with cool cars what their job is
where they work
why do i have such trouble getting in
maybe you just like
have your window up okay and then i'm
gonna come up to you and then okay okay
and i just saw this girl she's in this
nice car let's find out what she does
excuse me uh first off nice car i just
wanna know what do you do for a living
oh i'm a celebrity hamster trainer oh
oh okay well i like your car
interesting i'm about to give this car
back and i'm so sad because i've had
the best time with it ever but there was
one feature that i wanted to show you
guys if you've never seen this before
you may have actually seen this in one
of my ces videos from maybe two
three years ago when mclaren and oneplus
did a collaboration for this prototype
phone
where it had an electrochromic lens
cover so it basically
hid the camera so you couldn't see it
and it happened electronically
and it was basically inspired by the
mclaren so let's start this up real
quick
[Applause]
it's it's so beautiful so you'll see up
here on this little dashboard there's a
little sun and then a little moon and
this is how you
adjust the electrochromic sensitivity i
guess you could say so you either turn
it on or off
and then you can adjust how much light
is going through
and it's really cool because it just
automatically happens it's it's like
magic
so thank you again to mclaren for
hooking us up with this car for the
weekend my entire life has completely
it's just changed like everything after
driving this is
i don't know what i'm gonna do now
that i know that this is a thing
i don't know spring
is in the air